you're a fan of adele
um i like mac but dells are cool
not the dell computer david adele the
singer uh she's alright okay she's
alright i'm not a huge fan she
apparently is dating lebron's agent rich
paul right now that's random but
apparently she's been performing these
days
uh in london again
and fans are absolutely shocked by the
price of these tickets remember we we
talked about salt bay and the prices of
his
uh steaks and hamburgers and red bulls
and cokes and french fries and they were
outlandish let's see your your opinion
and our friends at home opinion on what
adele is charging to go to one of her
concerts okay so let's take a look at
some of these prices here basically so
general admission if you just want to
walk in the door it's 125 bucks
i don't think that's crazy and if you
want to basically enter the venue first
it's sort of like primary boarding you
know if you're getting on your flight
same tickets general mission but you get
to enter the building first 154 bucks
okay by the way these prices may or may
not be in british pounds so i think the
conversion is
uh 70 cents to a u.s dollar
meaning a u.s dollar
is the equivalent of 70 cents
in the uk
the british pound right right yes okay
yes yes i'm following all right so
basically you know this is 125 bucks 150
bucks is a dell worth the price of
dinner ask yourself that i don't know
um
now if you want some dope tickets some
gold tickets that they call it oh that's
375 bucks now we're talking holy moly
three hours to listen to adele saying
roll into the deep and hello
all right who's your favorite
artist
who would i pay that amount for
essentially that's what i'm getting at
cause like my favorite
well my favorite band doesn't play for
that amount of money i mean close but
i'm trying to think a chelsea game i'm a
huge chelsea yes i think if you
go blue you're wearing it right there
uh
i would pay that amount of money for a
great fan experience okay because i love
them that much and so if you love adele
that much i don't i wouldn't be
surprised i was gonna go there with this
for sure that it depends on how much you
love a dell yeah here let's read some of
these prices then i can have a little um
[Music]
therapy session on what these prices
cost and what what's worth it and what's
not sure so gold tickets 375 bucks um
which basically is the you know a third
of your rent yeah potentially that's top
tier that's the most expensive one
according to business insider the
average grocery spend for an individual
is 350 bucks a month just to put it in
perspective that's a month worth of
groceries yeah or adele to sing rolling
in the deep
um the vip experience 525 bucks uh which
is basically a car payment
525 dollars for a for a vip experience
for a deal wait so the three what was
the first one three what diamond
um gold tickets those are gold tickets
that's the cheapest 375 no the cheapest
was the general mission 125 so at 125
154
um
377 375 for gold and vip 525 they're
basically you know
a new tv or a car payment there you go
david's writing on his hand i don't know
what he's doing i'm writing these prices
down and if you want access to the vip
terrace i'll set you back 600 bucks so
that's a ps5 or something like that okay
um
you know i think about all the that's
two months worth of groceries right
there and the ultimate terrace tickets
top ticket there's more 800 bucks
at this one
oh oh 800
so that's a maybe you know
a little bit you know
maybe half your rent for the month
depending on where you live maybe the
majority of your rent so
the question is
what is it worth to go see your favorite
musician because let's not let's not
[ __ ] on adele here so there's a huge
adele fan out there yeah i think that's
definitely worth 150 bucks 300 bucks for
sure if you're a casual adele fan your
girl's like i'd like to go to the
concert now you gotta pay for two
tickets at 370 bucks now that's
six 700 bucks for adele
now it's how much do you love that girl
bro how much you love that girl make
your girl happy wait i have a question
for you do you know what these tickets
come with like at eight hundred dollars
do you hang out with her post no no
you're not hanging out with adele no
none of these included seats these are
good seats no meet and greet that's
that's that's not even an option right
now
here's some fans perspectives
um
opinions and then we can kind of get
into our stuff he said one fan said
if you want to feel poor right now go
and buy tickets for adele babes i love
you but i can't afford 180 bucks a
ticket 180 i guess that's the crossover
right there
um
but basically and my friend marcelo
basically said um
you know a lot of it
this is these are the prices of it
of to get it on a ticket exchange ticket
master stubhub but a lot of times people
will buy the tickets and then enter the
resale market and now your 125 ticket
now costs 225. or your 500 ticket now
costs 7.50 and this is where the prices
get
spiked up
anyway another fan says another adele
fan says i spent five days in greece for
less than the price of an adult yeah
so dude i had a whole week that week in
mexico shout out mexico that's why i'm
shout out to the country of mexico
um 400 bucks for a resort
uh food and drink included
a whole week
four hundred dollars yeah uh that's
right above gold
to see a dell for
90 minutes unbelievable right well look
some concert like for instance some of
my most memorable concerts i've ever
been to i've been to a rolling stones
concert nice i've been to uh red hot
chili peppers concert yeah justin
timberlake i do like to bring sexy back
sometimes dmx hey what my dog is
but you know what has the best value
because some of these concerts you get
in you got out it's two hours later you
see someone sing perform and it's
costing a couple hundred bucks you know
what i think is actually the best bang
for the buck are festivals
yeah festivals 100 yeah like we went to
rolling loud together yes i've been to
ultra coachella a lot of people love
burning man out there local there's
something called okeechobee three points
you know maybe that's 500 bucks for the
entire weekend i paid a hundred dollars
for 100 bucks and you're seeing multiple
multiple artists yeah and you can kind
of cross all over and
and uh you know so
one thing i will say is you can't put a
price on experience i mean you can
technically but experience seeing a
bunch of artists having fun getting you
know
partying with your friends having a good
time three-day festival
that's kind of dope yeah i guess yeah
it's all up to how much you really love
that artist but this is 800.
2 125 is general admission i'm lucky
that i like like the music i'm into 40
bucks to to get into shows i'm gonna go
see a band in two weeks what's the most
you would spend for your favorite band
my favorite band is a band from
gainesville called against me they play
like punk rock um the most i have spent
i think it was fifty dollars and even
then i was like i used to pay twenty
bucks to see them yeah um so i guess the
most i would pay to see them maybe
here's what i want to know to our
friends out there we got a couple uh we
got 100 or so people on live with us
thank you for being here on the size
cast episode 13. what is the most amount
that you'd be willing to spend for your
favorite artist the most amount
joe okay this guy joe in the comments
just posted uh i would just type adele
live on youtube yeah that's like saying
why would i buy an nft i'll just take a
screenshot of my favorite uh baseball
card
so yeah i agree george uh r.i.p dmx i
really so what's the most amount that
you would spend to see your favorite
artist okay who are the biggest artists
right now on the planet right now drake
drake uh lil nazax post malone
who else uh adele some country people
out there
jason uh
jay some trucking jason trucking we love
jason trucking jason right wing
i don't know there are some good uh
country what's the most that you would
spend all right so it's something
there's 69 bucks that's funny 150 200
100 for you too not a bad
deal that's great i saw metallica for 80
bucks when i was uh someone says they
paid 900 grand for a tupac concert yeah
that'd be a good one well yeah
um
yeah man maybe 100 150 at the most is
what i would pick anyway this this this
circles back to my initial point people
are spending a lot of money
now because they've been locked up
they've been cooped up
okay on food and beverage
and seeing some stuff in this case
listening to some stuff just be very
mindful of where you're spending this
edition these are not fixed costs rent
every month you know you're spending a
thousand bucks on rent two thousand
bucks whatever it is these are the stuff
that's like
this yeah go ahead no no i was gonna say
you know this is an additional three
four hundred bucks to see adele okay
cool like are you are you putting this
on a credit card are you going into more
debt is this money that you saved up
what is it and most i mean these artists
put out their schedule
months in advance you know where hey
this is the tour these are the dates
that's that's a treat yourself that's
your treat yourself moment yeah plan in
advance okay
silly white boy says the island boys i
am an island boy
okay anyway let us know in the comments
right here you know i would spend a good
amount of money on to go see who's that
drizzy drake really how much i like
drake how much
how much would i spend to see drake yeah
eight hundred no i wouldn't spend 80.
sir would you like the 800 package no
i'd spend i'd spend a couple hundred
bucks to see drake okay a couple hundred
bucks
i don't i wouldn't spend 500 bucks to
see drake no but then i wouldn't here we
go that's just the ticket then are you
getting drinks oh drinks of course you
get a drink so now what is that free
game yeah i'm just exaggerated
exactly all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke